[Music]
and I want to backt trick a little bit
because I want to go back to really the
fundamental question of why is it that
we that we have a gap or what is your
assessment on this Gap that we have that
requires um you know a United effort
from non-government workers you know
you're not a news journalist but a
High-Tech Communications professional to
come in and help tell the story of
Israel and help tell the story of what's
happening what did you and your
colleagues from different companies who
you mentioned you often compete with
even um that you came together under a
sense of unified Mission what was
that so I think that obviously uh we all
reside in Israel as I said before Israel
is our home um and I think just many of
us all of us really have seen for years
whether it was before we moved to Israel
um since we've lived in Israel growing
up in Israel you know whatever the case
may be for people um we've seen Israel
be portrayed over and over again
unfairly and inaccurately in the
media and we have Professionals in the
group from multiple countries I mean you
know obviously America Canada you know
the UK but also South Africa there's
Australians there's um there's really
all all kind kinds of um different
nationalities represented in the group
and I think the the common theme there
is that we've all seen the media be
unfair uh and inaccurate when reporting
on on Israel so we coming from that you
know coming from with that knowledge we
all realized okay like you know we we
need to step in here we need to step up
and I think the Gap really is
um I I don't know you know the ins and
outs of the different agencies
government agencies uh and and what
happened there and you know what might
have been lacking or not or um I think
there was a lot of confusion in the
early days I think no you know this
blindsided everyone um so I I I don't
want to be too critical of of any you
know agency or anything like that but
there was definitely a gap um from above
right so um whichever office is should
should have kind of maybe planned for
this in advance and uh not for this
obviously incident but I mean for just
you know representing Israel in the
media during wartime representing Israel
and the media during um during you know
some newsworthy event um it it it wasn't
really there and um I think online uh
social media it was it was there very
quickly right like there was a lot of um
I think the foreign Ministry has a great
team like there was a lot of stuff
coming out online on social media pretty
fast um but when we're talking about
kind of broadcast and and written
Publications um that seemed to be you
know there wasn't one place where
journalists could go and get a fixer
there wasn't one place where journalists
could go and get interviews with
families of the hostages it was kind of
whoever they knew they reached out to
and it was you know on the go on the Fly
and and that's kind of that's kind of
how it was and now it's gotten a little
bit more streamlined right like you have
a forum that represents the hostage uh
the hostages families and they are
helping with media for for on that front
and then you have um the government
press office that anyone I think over
2,000 journalists have come into Israel
since this happened which is a huge a
huge amount to deal with right and all
those people want briefings and all
those people want access to b-roll
footage and to you know to interviews
and and it's just it's a lot of work so
um again I I don't want to criticize too
much but I think there was just a lot of
work and it was like very fast and
nobody was expecting it and so it was
just kind of all hands on deck and and
and that's why we felt like a need to
really step in and help and so paint me
a picture of what this stepping into
help looks like so all hands on deck
massive maym different confusion 2,000
reporters
more than 200 families that are you know
in in from just from the hostages and
you have all the amilies of soldiers and
so so many different things happening
what is the the effort that we started
working on together as a
group so there were a few things uh that
kind of were working on uh we were
working on simultaneously in the early
days it was number one we wanted to have
like one place where journalists could
go to get b-roll footage um to get you
know f photographs to get interviews
firsthand interviews that were recorded
with the hostages families um we wanted
like just one folder one place very
simple shared with everyone uh where
they could go and get what they needed
so that was one of the things we did uh
very early on which was create this
um create this uh document this folder
for that um another thing was really
interviews like we wanted and by by the
way just in that that creation that
folder so obviously there's a part your
in creation is what materials go in how
do we portray these materials how do we
make sure that they're being portrayed
with the right
messaging what was there a process of
collaboration amongst you for that
creation or some decision making to
strategies how to do that um it was just
kind of volunteers for different things
so for example for that um one guy
decided he was going to start it I
joined him on that specific project and
then
um a bunch of people hand plus things
right so they would send it in the group
um where they would send it over email
and then we would upload it to to this
folder obviously a lot of the images are
very graphic um so we kind of set those
aside they're very brutal ones we set
aside in a special folder and and like
the warning on it so people knew you
know they weren't bombarded with these
images if they didn't want to be um so
we kind of organized it like that we
labeled everything clearly so we just
tried to make it as easy and clear as
possible so the journalists could really
just have that um information and have
have what they needed um you know I
think we've seen we've all seen kind of
the coverage and we're talking to you
know for example they're talking to a
hostage as loved one uh who's being
interviewed and in the background
there's Blu roll footage like a Gaza
building that that was like destroyed
you know like why why why are those
images being played in something that is
not being discussed at at that moment
you know somebody else is being
interviewed and it's not connected so uh
it's not directly connected so we wanted
we just wanted to make it as easy as
possible and as accessible as possible
for them um so that was that was kind of
one thing initially right off the bat
but what's been the what's been the
receptivity from the journalism side or
from the global side on on on working
with a professional group of people that
are you know just streamlining this
information or helping make sure that
it's fair it's it's a fair
and accurate portrayal of of what's
Happening you know what was the
receptivity there because there's a lot
of conversation about you know how how
information is being sent out and the
diligence that's being done on it before
it's being
disseminated yeah um I I think everyone
was very appreciative with the people
that we worked with um you know did they
use everything that we that we offer
them no you know did they did they
internalize and and then you know tell
the world the me every single message
that we kind of would have preferred for
them to no but I think the fact that we
made it um like I said easily accessible
to them we were friendly and
professional and really working hard
really 247 people were working around
the clock to to set up interviews to get
the right people that they were looking
for to get English speakers to get um
you know a lot of the people from the UK
the Outlets from the UK wanted to to
somebody from originally from the UK so
really trying to kind of do all that um
research and make those connections I
think that it definitely helped the
coverage right it helped balance out the
coverage um even now we kind of uh had
had an example the other day which was
um when yid uh lipit I think her name is
the the lady the 85y old woman hostage
so um you know she's she said a bunch of
different things and um and you know
some Outlets kind of ran with they just
focused in on like one specific thing
that she said uh which you know could be
construed as like oh you know Hamas
Hamas terrorists that took you know took
them were great you know and that's kind
of what some of the outlets chose to
focus on and we really went back and and
tried to like explain to them and work
with them and and actually got a a few
of the pieces and the headlines changed
after the fact which is almost almost
impossible but it did happen so um you
know even after the fact we're working
to try and like correct things or change
things so um yeah it's a big job and
it's not 100% it's not even I wouldn't
you know it's not even 70% of the time
uh we don't we don't get our wins but
every win is is a big deal and um and I
think just trying to accurately portray
the situ situation on the ground like
not you know and not having
it colored by by inaccuracy and so I I I
want to go back first of all I think
that's it's wonderful and I think that
it's it's such an important part of of
what's Happening Here so so thank you
for the great work that that all of you
are doing I I'm particularly curious
about the notion of you all working
together and coming together under the
sense of mission I think you mentioned
you know I'm obviously I'm some tech
Spas is a highly competitive space the
communication is a highly competitive
space um and yet you mentioned that one
of the things that that that you find
interesting Year and that I find
inspiring is the ability to come
together during a time of struggle to
put these this this the the daytoday um
Arena aside and and align on on a United
sense of mission and purpose tell me
what did that what was that like how did
you experience it how do you see it
um yeah I think we were all in it
together right it's kind of um I don't
want to compare it at all to to you know
the Army and um and people working
together in the Army but I mean it's
kind of like this you know media Army
right and so we all just had this shared
goal and this shared purpose of
portraying Israel fairly and accurately
in the media and really getting the
stories of the of the hostages out there
and their families right like that was
our number one goal um from the
beginning which was like to tell this
story accurately and to really um and to
really like tell the stories the
personal stories and and let the world
know who who were these people and um
how their loved ones are suffering and
and all of that so I think there was no
like moment where we kind of got
together and said you know it just it
just happened and it was very organic a
very organic process and we just had
like a very clear Mission um from the
beginning which was we wanted things to
be accurate in the media and and the
stories told so um nobody there there's
like no ego in the group right like it's
just like okay who has this person who
knows that person who has somebody from
CNN who has you know and it's just it's
very quick it's very easy it's very
seamless it's just uh we we're always
communicating sharing sharing files like
whatever it may be so
um yeah it's been great I think just
this shared sense of mission is is
what's made it work and and what's been
your personal experience from October 7
how has this how has the past 18 days
we're now October 25th of the time
recording how how is the how have the
past 18 days been like for you from the
initial shock of you know the holiday
going out and all a sudden discovering
that we're in the middle of this of this
event to or not inial event undermines
it this terrible terrible situation how
how has this been for you you know
you're you're taking actionable actions
here yeah I'll tell you Michel like it's
been horrible like it has for everyone
right I I'm generally a very positive
person and I just felt this like
incredible weight um for the for the
past what is it 18 days um you know I
wake up with a pit in my stomach I go to
sleep with a pit in my stomach um my
daughter just celebrated her fourth
birthday and while you know it was a
lovely celebration I mean all I could
think about you know the majority of the
time was like the kids who are in some
tunnel in some hole somewhere um you
know passing birthdays and whatever else
with like with just like in hell um so
it's it's horrible but at the same time
uh I I always try to kind of find the
silver lining and I think you know our
little comms cabal group is is just you
know one very small indication of this
but I mean there's just been Unity among
the people of Israel in every in every
way right like from you know real estate
agents finding people housing to people
cooking in a citizen's you know kitchen
you know preparing in Tel Aviv preparing
like 5,000 meals for people in the South
and to donations to I mean just
everything right like everything so I
think that's kind of what I take away
from it that's positive is like this
Unity you know you back it up before
October 7th it was like a you know
everyone at each other's throats and and
literally in a split second I mean the
whole country changed and came together
and I think um you know it's a horror
and and for me personally I can't just
sit back and do nothing like I I feel
like I have to act and I have to keep
moving and I have to do something so you
know one of the ways I do that is
through this Communications work but the
unity uh of the people is really what I
gives me hope and strength and um and
we'll just overcome this we have to
overcome this we don't have a
choice and Rachel thank you so much for
all this time and the effort and the
energy and the Beautiful work that
you've been doing and and and I love how
you exemplified the both being so action
oriented and taking matters into your
own hands I think that's really one of
the things that I've been so inspire by
here is how how you know people in all
around the country and the world have
been coming together and saying no we
see something that's wrong here we're
going to take action we're gonna and
we're going to do something about it
ourselves and not only that but doing it
with people that we both work within the
day today and people that are in the
same industry as you and perhaps are in
the day today it's it's a it's a
coopertition not just collaboration so I
I think that it's it's phenomenal and
it's a fantastic um effort and Endeavor
and then it's iring one that I and a
message that I think a lot of people
should hear so thank you very very much
and continue making a positive impact
yeah thank you so much and I just want
to give a lot of credit to everyone in
the group I mean I just do a little
piece of it but there's people that are
working way harder than me and uh and
really just making a difference on the
media front so thank you to all of them
wonderful thank you
[Laughter]
Rachel